and then in Australia in Australia I
think there's been through already just
in this summer there's been three death
by great white shark Jesus Christ Jesus
I don't like that at all
also don't swell so I'm not swimming in
Australia it's rare don't care that's
what they keep saying it's rare oh my
god yes I hear about all the time yeah
they have box jellyfish they have
[ __ ] great whites the too many things
in Australia that I I'll stay on the
sand I'm not getting in that water my I
told you a long time ago the girl I was
dating a girl who let me she said I have
to go back to South Africa so I said my
sister's fiance was killed right in
front of her she just saw blood they
never saw him again
a great white just went I'll take him
I don't mean to laugh but it's just and
she said I just saw I just heard a
splash and I saw blood and I never saw
him again he just disappeared it's a
giant fish I mean God knows and took him
entirely
it's like these scientists were down
there with um with these cameras and
they were studying great whites and
whatever the kid one of the great whites
went I'm turning around I'm gonna eat
you put the guy and just went down but
that's what they do men I would imagine
but it's also like they this shark this
great white who bit this dude flag off
and kill them they found they salt they
they had a drone over it it was the
biggest great light you've ever seen and
cuz if it kills a person they usually
want to try and kill them well that
shark went oh man it seems like I upset
people
well I'm should we go super deep and
then they lost that's right because it's
the ocean oh he does it's a mile deep
white shark yeah the tiger I guess makes
sense although it's like you have this
kind of nothing that's not that's that
that's not fair either because the tiger
you have to keep in a cage because it's
I know and they're like well once the
tiger tastes blood it's like all right
well don't put in a position to taste
human blood again don't kill it well
yeah I mean obviously a terrible tragedy
for her family awful I should say those
caption I don't know next giant great
white like that
[ __ ] huge dude huge that's like Sammy
Hagar every time I'm down in San Diego I
remember this very well I'm looking down
there and I'm like man and they were
having a they were having a triathlon or
a big group swim and I'm like looking at
all the seals as they're swimming that
big oh [ __ ] blue water and a deep
water and I'm like you know I just feel
like there's a lot of splashing going on
well Brendan about a month later a
dentist or a doctor or whoever had he
was bitten in half by a great white in
exactly that swim fin he was swimming
and a great white was like you know what
you're slower than the seal and I'm
hungry yeah job I mean if there's a way
to go that's it I guess laughs he
doesn't even make real big time news you
guys even know about it for God's sakes
so now even that's not making news I'll
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue Oh what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]